every time presidential elections take
place in the United States the spotlight
falls on how the American legislative
system works so let's take a closer look
at it and compare it with Europe's much
younger legislature Congress goes back
to the mid 1770s when the Revolutionary
War against British colonial rule back
then there was called the Second
Continental Congress one of his first
achievements to declare the 13 American
colonies independent the birth of the
United States of America the European
Parliament rose from the ashes of World
War two in 1951 to be precise as the
common assembly of the European Coal and
Steel community before Runner of the EU
its membership then national parliament
members from France Belgium Germany
Netherlands Luxembourg and Italy today
Congress comprises two chambers the
House of Representatives 435 seats and
the Senate 100 both are split between
Republicans and Democrats with a few
independents in the larger house the
European Parliament by contrast
currently has eight main groups from the
EU member-states reflecting all
political shades Europe center-right
Christian Democrats are the largest
followed by the center-left Social
Democrats then center-right
conservatives there are also just over
50 non-attached members sitting outside
the main groups and mostly for the far
right as for Paris things are very
different across the pond Congress sets
the federal budget and tax collection
foreign policy senior appointments and
it can impeach the president vice
president and all civil officers of the
United States the European Parliament
shares its powers with the EU Member
States the console it flow decides and
can block that you use annual budget it
elects the Commission and has many
supervisory powers but it can't initiate
legislation or raise taxes on Foreign
Relations it can debate and
one other key difference the European
Parliament speaks the e used 24 official
languages language